So the next game against Prince
Panic somehow I've
played so many times already, it's
Hendrix from the Netherlands
who somehow has what he has again 2300
who
sometimes plays around here with
really strange numbers for his standards,
actually really
really a strong player
and somehow often
seems to have problems here, a little
slower I think sometimes even
slower than me, which somehow
says a lot
so um we once again played freely here with Löffler B5,
where I typically don't know my way around very well
Yes, the position seems a
bit uncomfortable for Black if
he comes straight away with the four,
well,
but what if I can now
take F3, maybe or take F3 once on d4
and then take E4, is that or is that
too daring for
him?  I also always swap between E5,
which is also unpleasant.
Well, I take it first and see what
you can look at again later, so
if I take E4 now, do
one and then the five, maybe
jump 5 ne
F5, you can
somehow play it as if it wasn't  OK, no, well,
let's try it,
yes, the five comes Springer E5, that
looks kind of stupid because of the point C6. Going
back is out of the
question anyway, well, let's try F5, although
that looks kind
of risky, let's say that
as I see it  just also 5 that
I wanted to do
I could also take it but in a
knight is just no knight is
E5 doesn't work so well
I can take it
I have unbelievable I have half
my time because of David moves oh yeah well
that's definitely going to happen  Here again he's
in a time crunch,
well, let's see what he can do,
moves like Queen please three or
so C4 only they're unpleasant, they always
make castling difficult first,
that would probably be an
unpleasant move, yes Queen B3
not then do B8 or something like that  here Queen
E6 no, that looks uncomfortable, well
at least I invested a
bit of time
because the position is, I
think it's strange for me
then B3 or so C4
if he plays something else,
I think I can do it
quite well up here so that should be  then it wo
n't be so bad, yes, as already said,
he's a good player,
yes, what do you do with it now, yes
with that D6 looks terribly slow,
you can't give anything back to
calm the position,
that was probably all too risky,
no, I don't see any other move  I have to
prevent it, it won't help
if he comes and the whole
position will fall apart,
so now do the eight
for a moment. If he now plays rook of
1 I can probably
take it, but it's clear that
the queen is stronger in that position because of
the rook  I'm still on the A8,
okay, that's somehow a
relief, or at least
I hope that it helps in some way,
so we have the five of them, I could even swap,
I could still play runner F6 first,
but he's going to hurt you, oh
God, nonsense with that  the five
and CD Springer E5
yes that's dangerous no yes but let's do
one no choice probably
18 man oh man
so yes
I'm still in the e line
so otherwise look like F3 it's
very unpleasant that's
why I don't think so  that I
now have to
make tempos for the knight here, even if he
can take it now,
I have to have one more move for this so
that I can still play King F7 or King
D7 here otherwise everything will fall
apart and
this beautiful one also hangs after F3
Pawn,
yes, I played it all way too risky,
probably
well, if it's easier now, make four, okay,
yes, that'll probably work too, but
two more pawns, what else do you want to
beat the channel, yes,
I couldn't play it like that, yes,
I don't know much about it either  In the
variant, you always notice straight away
when your opponents have a bit of an idea.
Somehow then
it becomes more than difficult. Yes, the
end game is won for I know
I only have a little bit of
activity but also just a little
bit. Well, let's see, even though that's
a little bit  a bit
unpleasant now, no, whenever it
splinters, the
material is put back, the material is
still hanging,
yes,
in the end, the time will be right here,
among other things, for
eight seconds I let
a little air in again, but I
won what I always think, yes,
of course it was strange
Here
probably my first thought
was also the five in the position here
D5 should also work, maybe I do
n't know yet if something bad is going to
happen, I actually don't think so, yes
the five was probably really too
risky,
yes the position is the position is
stupid there  If you don't get out well
then you have to play five games then I can
go up properly